[Music]
no that's not your eyes playing tricks
on you that's beyonce for daughter blue
ivy and blue's total look-alike little
sis roomie the rare roomy sighting is
thanks to a new video b just released
for her latest ivy park collection where
the sisters pose together with their
famous mama first queen b rocks a blue
bustier bodysuit with matching blue
earrings and a sequined plaid jacket
then she matches with her daughters in
black and white plaid at leisure b
carries roomy and blue holds a soccer
ball i was so excited but blue and roomy
aren't the only famous siblings in the
video check out reese witherspoon's
look-alike daughter ava and her little
bro deacon plus there's some major nba
star power here's james harden and jalen
green and the late kobe bryant's
daughter 18 year old natalia looks
fierce in a variety of chic looks feels
like a dream but back to beyonce this
isn't the first time her kids with hubby
jay-z have appeared with them on screen
back in february blue struck a pose in
this campaign video and get this grandma
tina knowles lawson revealed on
instagram that she wasn't originally
supposed to be featured but she talked
her way into joining the photo shoot
tina wrote in the caption quote no she
was not supposed to be in it she was
just hanging out and got dressed and i
guess she said i'm not gonna tell you
what i could do i'm gonna show you
what's the best thing about being a mom
so far it's just i have such a full life
i feel like now i know the reason why i
was born and just last month blue stole
the spotlight yet again
[Applause]
there's blue crashing mom and dad's
romantic date night in a video for
tiffany and coke while her famous
parents are trying to enjoy a chic car
ride complete with pizza and champagne
blue decides to hop in and get in on the
fun
[Music]
[Applause]
one thing's for sure the family that
works together stays together and we
can't wait to see the carter's next
collab
[Music]
i need
[Music]
you